my day job is publishing skeptic
magazine and directing the skeptic
Society which is a 501 C 3 non-profit
science education organization I got
interested in the topics which is pretty
much any of the super interesting topics
related to science and religion and
spirituality and cults and free will and
determinism and God you know you know
pretty much all the great topics I'm
interested in really goes back to being
in college and I was a born-again
Christian hey I'm Dave Rubin and this is
the Rubin report reminder everybody you
can get all our videos and audio
podcasts absolutely ad-free
and early at Rubin report comm and
joining me today is the publisher of
skeptic magazine host of the science
salon podcast and author of the new book
giving the devil his due Michael Shermer
welcome back to the Rubin report good to
be back the Tournament of Champions
continues we've had a couple technical
difficulties today to make this thing
happen but here we are I I know that as
a man of faith you're gonna pray that
our connection does I'm praying away I'm
not gonna try to pray away the gay for
you but I'm gonna try to pray away the
coronavirus bugs in our computer systems
here it's the 5g you see oh it's
definite it's definitely the 5g it's
coming for everybody it's spreading
Corona Vice coronavirus or the rest of
it all right there's a ton I want to get
to here because I really love this book
and I just said to you right before we
started that so much in in my book is
well we really cover the topics but come
to slightly different conclusions on a
couple things and the way we approach
the topics is a little bit different
each time but before we get to the book
itself you've written 16 books and as a
guy that just wrote one and knows what
it takes to write one how do you
possibly not only come up with enough
material but enough sort of personal
fortitude and patience and and all of it
to just be able to sit there and put all
of those thoughts out 16 times and quite
successfully by the way it's not like
nobody's reading these things you know
well thank you I appreciate that well
first of all I'm 65 so I've got a couple
decade
zanya almost dis cumulative time but I
also started riding in my 20s when I was
in college I actually always wanted to
be a writer and then by the time I got
to my early 30s I had written quite a
bit that wasn't published just you know
just practicing stuff and trying to get
things published such that by my first
book let's see in 1997 so I was 30
let's see 33 no let's see no 43 you know
I had quite a bit of material so and 43
at my first book with you see that's
right but so each book kind of ends with
a question of sorts or in my mind anyway
that's the next book and it's also a
strategy when you're cutting because I
always I usually write too much material
and I think oh I really don't want to
give this up and I can talk myself into
doing that by saying I'll put it in the
next book and then it shortens that
books you know feel like you've wasted
your time
but person by temperament I feel like if
I don't write pretty much every day it's
like if I don't go work out if I don't
ride my bike I feel anxious like I
really need to write I just have kind of
a need for it and I know other people
like you know Isaac Asimov was let that
way apparently Stephen King's like that
they just got a crank out the material
because it feels good it's just sort of
what I do you know like the an artist
paints I write whatever and so I find a
lot of you know it's not a chore I don't
have you know writer's block per se i
time block I just said you know I just
need more time because I enjoy it one of
the things that I really like that you
do and it's not just in this book it's
it's in I really all of your books or at
least the last few since I've known you
is you give credit to a lot of the other
current thinkers that are talking about
these things and I think that's a that's
actually a kind of unique trait because
a lot of people want to sort of sit
there and make it seem like they came up
with all this but even I was looking at
the I was looking at the blurbs in the
back of the book and actually it's a
it's a Rubin report reunion over here
because you've got Steven Pinker Jordan
Peterson maybe and strossen Nick
Christakis Amy Chua and Jonathan hate
and I reference
they've all been on the show which which
is nice but but that is one of the
things that I like about this book
because you reference a lot of these
people and their ID
is as sort of the starting point for
starting point or maybe mid point for
how you think about things were you
always that way that you would sort of
hear somebody and kind of mirror what
you think against them yeah to a certain
extent but as a writer and as a consumer
of many other books I can see some
authors are more generous about
crediting where their ideas came from
and and sort of tracking for the reader
how they came up with their thesis of
the book or whatever others not so much
I'm not gonna name any names but some
people do write in a way like they just
came out of this whole cloth it just
popped into my brain like the muses you
know and that no ideas happen like that
we all build on each other everybody
does and you know in scholarly papers
you have to cite just tons and tons and
tons of references you know and that's
why sometimes the reference sections are
as long as the papers themselves so you
know so I always felt like well I want
to be generous and just sort of honest
and say that here's where I came up with
these ideas because of these three
authors or these 16 sources or whatever
anyway so I just got in the habit of
doing that just from training as a
experimental psychologist initially and
then a historian of science you just
have to do that but just personally I
feel you know when I see that someone
like Richard Dawkins is very generous
about that he's his deep thinker you
know deciding where all these ideas come
from quoting other people and it's like
I like that I'm gonna I want to make
sure I do that - yeah so one other thing
before we dive specifically into the
topics in the book because you have now
been on the Rubin report at least six
times which places you at number one
which I'm sure despite your despite your
rather lofty resume I'm sure that's
clearly at the top of the list but for
somebody that's watching this right now
that just doesn't know anything about
you can you just give me a two or
three-minute sort of recap on on how you
kind of became the skeptic skeptic yeah
well you know my day job is publishing
skeptic magazine and directing the
skeptic Society which is a 501 C 3
non-profit science education
organization I got interested in the
topics which is pretty much any of the
super interesting topics related to
science and religion and spirituality
and cults and free will and determinism
and God you know you know pretty much
all the great topics I'm interested in
really goes back to being in college and
I was a born-again Christian I was in
1971 when I was in 11th grade I had two
close friends who were interested in
converting me I didn't even know what
that meant really and George and Frank
so George had a really cute sister and
invited me to church I thought well okay
here's my chance but but then I got to
the church it was Presbyterian Church in
Glendale California and that that
Minister was unbelievably dynamic and
just really motivating and at the end he
said come on up and you can accept Jesus
the whole thing will happen right here
and I'm like all right I'm going so what
have I didn't even know I was doing
really but I did it and then you know
took it pretty seriously and then I went
to Pepperdine University which is a
Church of Christ cool and very
conservatives and you know Gerald Ford
came to speak and Edward Teller even
gave his mutual assured destruction
speech and everyone was dying right and
Atlas Shrugged and all that you know
pretty much the what you'd expect but
then when I went to graduate school I
kind of drifted away from being
religious mainly for two reasons one you
know studying social psychology
anthropology sociology you know I could
see that other people's religious belief
systems are very much context dependent
geographically dependent you know had I
been born in India
I very likely would not be Christian had
I been born 10,000 years ago that there
would be no Christians right so you know
it's it seemed to me that that that
doesn't make it wrong but it makes it
more likely to to be mythically true as
our friend Peterson would say not
empirically true and we're gonna get
into that yeah yeah so but but then also
the problem of evil that theodicy what
you know why bad things happen to good
people and and I'm not talking about you
know like human volition of homicide or
war or something like that but just like
innocent children dying of leukemia or
you know thousands of children dying
from starvation every year and so on
it's like why would a good God allow
that to happen I know there's tons of
books and papers by theists and
theologians about this but to me they've
never squared that circle they've never
solved that problem other than like
rabbi Kushner's famous book when bad
things happen to good people he is
concluded
was God simply can't do anything about
it he's just not on he's not omniscient
I mean he's not omnipotent he may know
everything but he can't stop evil okay
so that's one solution another one is
well there just is and and that's the
simpler solution and that explains a lot
because if you understand the laws of
physics and say the second law of
thermodynamics entropy just [ __ ] happens
you know just it's mostly just random
and you know there's very little
directionality to why things happen
other than just statistical
probabilities and that's it there's
nothing to explain you know it's like
the corona virus what's the cause you
know 500 years ago it would have been
you know well women have been cavorting
with demons in the middle of the night
or the Jews poison the well or you know
some of these can a crazy supernatural
paranormal and racist bigoted targeting
of people's to explode well we don't do
that anymore except for the 5g craziness
because you know we live in an age of
science and hopefully we've moved past
that so to me once I left the church and
really religion I was still interested
in answering the big questions like well
then where did the universe came from if
there's no God what's the origins of
morality
what about consciousness and you know
why is the universe tuned the way it is
where'd all this diversity of life come
from and you know all the great
questions from a secular perspective so
in trying to answer it myself I thought
well I want to write some this is what
I'm gonna write about from a skeptical
perspective so my little niche my lane
as they say is you know kind of on the
margins of science the pseudoscience and
the paranormal the supernatural the sort
of controversial stuff that most
mainstream scientists don't deal with
that's my lane and from there I can
tackle the great questions just from my
particular perspective if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about academia instead of
non-stop yelling check out our academia
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlists there all
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell